bonjour et bienvenue sur public sénat
vous allez poursuivre dans un instant en
direct de l'hémicycle la séance de
questions cribles les questions cribles
vous le savez ce sont des questions très
précises que posent les sénateurs un
ministre alors aujourd'hui le thème
c'est l'accès à la justice et la justice
de proximité et la ministre qui est là
pour y répondre c'est la garde des
sceaux
christiane taubira on se retrouve tout
de suite après du prochainement
quelle que soit la piste envisagée
pouvez-vous nous assurer que le réseau
juridictionnelle n'en pâtira pas et que
soit privilégié la présence d'un
tribunal sur chaque territoire au plus
près des femmes et les hommes
par exemple s'il était retenu la piste
du tribunal de première instance
il ne faudrait pas que cela conduise à
la suppression de nouvelles
implantations judiciaire ensuite il est
aussi nécessaire que soit préservée la
spécialisation des magistrats car comme
le souligne le rapport
les magistrats spécialisés tient à leur
spécialisation et peuvent craint que le
tribunal de première instance
entendu comme un outil de mutualisation
effectifs de magistrats de greffiers
temps à diluer cette spécialisation au
nom d'une préoccupation dans leurs
pratiques concernant l'accès du citoyen
la justice il ne serait effectivement
pas pertinent de revenir sur la
tradition française de certains
tribunaux de première instance
tels les conseils des prud'hommes les
tribunaux pour enfants ou les
juridictions sociale merci madame la
ministre vous avez la parole
le président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs adam la
sénatrice que kamal je peux vous
rassurer tout de suite la réforme
judiciaire que nous envisageons ne
visera ne vise pas et n'aura absolument
pas pour effet de fermer le moindre
aussi judiciaire concernant votre
préoccupation sur ce que vous appelez la
spécialisation des magistrats et donc
nos juridictions spéciales par exemple
la juridiction des prud'hommes et
diverses juridictions sociale vous savez
que là aussi il y aurait un besoin de
cohérence
mais la spécialité de ces juridictions
sera préservé la préoccupation c'est
d'assurer la proximité
c'est à dire de faire en sorte que le
justiciable est le plus près de lui un
site judiciaire qui lui rende les
services attendus pour ces raisons je
peux vous assurer aussi qui n'est pas
prévu de fermer le moindre aux sites
judiciaires et j'entends bien là aucun
site judiciaire y compris les maisons de
la justice et du droit
le président la république s'est engagé
sur la proximité de la justice sur
l'efficacité de la justice sur la
diligence de la justice ce sont nos
objectifs
et vous savez que j'ai donc engagé
ouvert quatre grands chantiers de façon
à aboutir une réforme judiciaire je
prends le temps nécessaire j'espère
aller plus vite mais la constitution des
groupes le temps de travail des groupes
le temps de consultation savais que je
me déplace abondamment dans les
juridictions tout cela nécessite du
temps donc je me suis résigné à prendre
le temps nécessaire
le 10 et le 11 janvier nous aurons un
grand événement à la maison de l'unesco
au cours duquel seront présentés les
préconisations de ces quatre grands
chantiers
l'office du juge au 21ème siècle
magistrats du 21e siècle avec son équipe
d'assistance spécialisée le les
juridictions du 21e siècle et c'est là
que nous revenons au rapport de madame
classe et de monsieur détraigne rapport
de très grande qualité je les ai reçus
récemment à la chancellerie et bien
entendu aussi la modernisation de
l'action publique
évidemment je tiendrai au fur et à
mesure informé la représentation
nationale de l'évolution de ces
réflexions il me reste encore à recevoir
de rapport mais surtout vous êtes
invités à ce grand événement parce que
votre parole pointe elle est extrêmement
importante et je connais la qualité des
travaux qui sont produits ici nous nous
en inspirons aussi et nous arriverons à
écrire une belle réforme judiciaire dans
l'objectif majeur est vraiment de servir
le citoyen merci madame la sénatrice
merci à madame la ministre la garde des
sceaux pour ces quelques précisions
je crois importante est en tout cas qui
vise à rassurer à la fois les
professionnels de la justice les
organisations syndicales
plus largement je le disais les
citoyennes et les citoyens qui sont
confrontés et qui ont affaire à la
justice
et puis aussi les élus locaux qui
parfois se sentent un petit peu dépourvu
quand la présence judiciaire a été dans
les années précédentes réduite
bien évidemment nous serons attentifs au
reste
tu as des travaux qui sont menés
actuellement et qui seront rendus
publics sur la justice du 21ème siècle
le sénat à travers la commission des
lois également et travaille également
sur un certain nombre de rapports et de
propositions nous y sommes présents et
nous souhaitons bien évidemment que dans
le pluralisme et la diversité des idées
qu'ils puissent société qui est ici
exprimer par dont nous construisons
réellement celle justice nécessaires
merci merci la parole est à présent de
l'âme esther benbassa pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'article 13 de la convention européenne
de sauvegarde des droits de l'homme
dispose à ce titre que je suis toute
personne dont les droits et libertés
reconnus dans la présente convention été
violée a droit à l'octroi de recours
effectif devant une instance nationale
la convention ne garantit donc pas
seulement un procès équitable mais exige
également que soit assuré le droit d
d'accès effective au juge on regarde ces
principes plusieurs institutions
européennes se sont prononcés en faveur
de l'instauration de recoules collective
en anglais class action le 11 juin 2013
la commission européenne avait
recommandé aux états membres de se doter
de mécanismes de recours collectif pour
garantir la halle aux justiciables
elle est un accès effectif à la justice
vous déclariez vous même madame la
ministre en juin 2010 votre intention de
permettre les recours collectif afin de
garantir une meilleure efficacité de la
justice et pour que la réparation des
petits litiges soit effective je vous
cite le projet de loi sur la
consommation a sans conteste ouvert une
brèche et je suis l'auteur au nom du
groupe écologiste d'une proposition de
loi qui devrait être examinée le 13
février prochain dans l'espace réservé
de notre groupe à notre assemblée visant
à instaurer un recours collectif en
matière discrimination et de lutte
contre les inégalités
ma question madame la ministre est la
suivante considérant que les standards
européens sont en faveur du recours
collectif dans quels domaines et dans
quel délai pensez vous qu'une telle
procédure puisse être intégré à nos
droits
merci
merci madame à ministre président
mesdames les sénatrices yeux messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice esther
benbassa vous avez raison de rappeler
les recommandations de la commission qui
demande que les états veille à assurer
un niveau élevé de protection des
citoyens des justiciables et que les
suisses ces justiciables obtenir
réparation des préjudices et notamment
des préjudices de masse dont le prix le
projet de loi parce que bon c'est une
petite loi pour l'instant puisque et ce
texte arrive en deuxième lecture le
projet de loi donc sur la consommation
comme vous venez de le dire
incontestablement ouvert une possibilité
pour ses préjudices cyrielle de montants
souvent faibles et qui permettent
d'apporter réparation à un ensemble de
personnes
vous avez déposé une proposition de loi
vous savez quel intérêt j'ai regardé ce
texte et je me suis préoccupé de savoir
effectivement et qu'elle diligence nous
pouvons nous pourrions y travailler ce
texte soulève un problème qui n'est pas
insurmontable mais qu'il nous faut
travailler c'est veiller à ce que ces
procédures ne sont pas pénalisante
compte tenu de la réparation qui est
actuellement reconnu individuellement
parce que lorsque les procédures sont
individuelles le justiciable a droit à
une réparation intégrale
il ne faudrait pas qu'une procédure
général pénalise la possibilité
d'apprécier très exactement le préjudice
et ses effets et d'apporter une bonne
réparation
c'est que c'est donc un point sur lequel
nous travaillons encore je vous remercie
d'ailleurs de la disponibilité que vous
montrez pour travailler avec le cabinet
l'administration de la chancellerie
nous allons avancer mais nous avons
évidemment ce souci j'ai d'ailleurs avec
ma collègue de l'égalité des droits des
femmes et mon collègue de l'intérieur
chargé madame pétroliers
peco rue rivollier pardon qui est
conseiller référendaire à la cour de
cassation il me semble c'est bien ça
nous l'avons chargé d'une étude qui nous
permettra d'apporter quelques réponses
qui alimenteront la réflexion celle que
nous conduisons avec vous votre souci
est absolument légitime
nous voulions simplement ce que ce soit
réellement un progrès que par
inadvertance
on ne pénalise pas les citoyens merci
merci madame et monsieur et madame la
mini jeux vous remercie pour ses
réponses mais il faut faire avancer le
droit comme vous le savez et chaque
génération a fait quelque chose dans ce
centre le droit n'est pas immuable et
j'espère que vous nous aiderait pour
régler ses problèmes de procédures afin
que ce texte puisse servir disons de
deux corps pour les autres textes qui
viendront sur les recours collectif
concernant l'environnement la santé et
le reste je compte sur la chancellerie
et sur vos détermination madame la
ministre
sachez que le avec mon collègue monsieur
call cac alten bas qui est le rapporteur
de cette loi nous menons sans arrêt des
auditions depuis un bon moment et nous
continuerons et non nous conjuguons nos
efforts pour arriver un résultat
plausible est correct et evo enfin
disons progressistes pour nos
concitoyens merci madame la ministre
merci alors pour la question suivante la
parole et à notre collègue stéphane
mazars pour le groupe r d assise sur le
président madame la garde des sceaux mes
chers collègues
madame la garde des sceaux le droit pour
tout justiciable à un recours effectif à
la justice induit un accès réel au juge
ainsi la réforme de la carte judiciaire
initiée par madame dati était certes
nécessaire mais demeure fortement
critiquable dans la forme qu'elle a
prises et dans ses résultats
vous en connaissez les raisons
calendrier précipité absence de réelle
concertation ignorance des réalités
administratives et géographique et
partant oubli de la nécessaire proximité
entre le citoyen et son juge
la refonte qui en a résulté nous le
savons a
villégier des critères quantitatifs au
détriment de la réalité des territoires
nous avons pris note de votre volonté de
remettre les choses à plat et à la suite
du rapport daele les pistes évoquées
telles que la réouverture de certaines
tgi ou la création de chambre détachée
constituent des réponses sérieuses et
pragmatiques et nous les saluons
mais attention attention à ne pas
laisser une nouvelle fois de côté
certains territoires pour lesquels la
seule création d'un guichet unique de
grèce pourrait apparaître comme un
pis-aller largement insuffisant
l'objectif de proximité d'accessibilité
a été également ignoré lors de la mise
en place des pôles de l'instruction
cette réforme initiée par la loi du 5
mars 2007 a ainsi subi de multiples
reports quant à son application est
votre produit de loi relatif à la
collégialité de l'instruction prévoit
d'ailleurs un nouveau report au 1er
septembre 2014 cette réforme ne va pas
sans susciter l'inquiétude des
justiciables des auxiliaires de justice
dans les territoires déjà fragilisés il
est en effet prévu de ne pas maintenir
l'existence de vue instruction m'isoler
dans les juridictions elle fera paul
certes des pôles de l'instruction
pourront être créés lorsque l'activité
de la juridiction le justifiera mais
vous comprendrez que si nous espérons
beaucoup de ce remariage des territoires
nous ne souhaitons pas encore une fois
que le seul critère du chiffre préval
pour décider de ces nouvelles
implantations
la question du mariage ne peut enfin il
y aurait 7 de l'aide juridictionnelle
pour les justiciables une justice de
proximité sans à nantes seulement de
l'accès physique aux juges mais aussi
d'un réel accès à la défense de leurs
droits
l'absence de proximité de la justice
nous le savons fragilise le secteur aidé
car elle remet en cause de fête des
principes aussi fondamentaux que celui
du libre choix de son avocat qui ne peut
être à la fois proche de son client et
éloigné du lieu où la justice est rendue
au vu de ces éléments
comment comptez vous madame le garde des
sceaux garantir une justice de qualité
pour tous et en tout lieu
vous avez la parole dans le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mazars il ya deux sujets forts
dans votre question la question de la
territorialité donc de la proximité
d'autre part la question
la collégialité de l'instruction vous
savez bien que nous n'avons pas choisi à
la chancellerie de travailler
exclusivement sur les chiffres nous ne
pouvons pas les ignorer les évacuer nous
voulons qu'il y ait de la cohérence et
de la performance dans l'activité
judiciaire donc
nous tenons compte des volumes
d'affaires des volumes d'affaires
civiles d'affaires pénales mais ça n'est
pas le seul critère vous savez que nous
faisons plutôt un maillage d'indicateurs
pour ce qui concerne la collégialité
alors pour ce qui concerne les
territoires vous savez que sur la base
de ces éléments mais nous en nous tenant
compte de paramètres correctifs d'une
certaine façon puisque nous tenant
compte aussi de la distance vous savez
que je me suis rendu à rodez il y a
quelques mois que j'ai rencontré à
d'autres endroits aussi monsieur le
président il est à d'autres endroits
ce fait de multiples déplacements mais
je crois que c'est la meilleure solution
pour comprendre il faut connaître parce
que juste vous entendre d'ici vous qui
êtes immergés dans vos réalités
territoriales si je me contente de vous
écouter que je ne viens pas voir sur
place et que je ne me fais pas guidée
par vous sur place
évidemment je n'ai qu'une vision
partielle de la réalité je ne peut
apporter que des réponses est parfaite
j'ai l'ambition d'apporter de bonnes
réponses pour ce qui concerne donc nous
nous voyons prochainement parce que
effectivement compte tenu de la distance
de millau à rodez par exemple il y a
lieu de regarder les choses pas
seulement au niveau du volume d affaires
mais aussi au niveau de l'efficacité de
la proximité par rapport aux
justiciables sur la collégialité de
l'instruction vous savez que j'ai
présenté le projet de loi en conseil des
ministres dès le mois de mai et nous
l'avons donc que présenter devant
l'assemblée nationale
sauf que nous n'avons pas encore obtenu
son inscription à l'ordre du jour
puisque ce projet de loi vise à aménager
les conditions de la collégialité d'un
sociaux de façon à ne pas alourdir
inutilement le l'instruction par une
collégialité systématique ce qui est
l'objet de la loi de mars 2007 donc nous
aurions été prêts nous pour
l'application en janvier 2014 parce que
je tiens pas vous je crois vous le savez
nous avons assez des chances depuis 18
mois je pense que lorsque les lois sont
adoptées il faut qu'elle soit appliquée
donc moi j'avais l'ambition quand même
de d'éviter un nouveau report d'éviter
un nouveau report c'est pour ça qu'au
niveau du calendrier gouvernemental nous
sommes complètement dans les temps en
ayant adopté le texte en mai 2013
constatant que l'année allait s'achever
et que le débat n'aurait pas lieu et que
l'adoption du texte n'aurait pas permis
d'éviter l'application systématique en
janvier
1014 de cette collégialité telles que
contenues dans la loi de 2007
j'ai demandé donc que nous puissions
introduire un amendement au projet de
loi de finances 2014 de façon à reporter
d'un an l'application de la loi de 2007
ce qui laisse le temps pour la
discussion et l'adoption j'espère de
cette nouvelle loi pour laquelle j'ai ce
projet de loi pour lequel évidemment
j'ai procédé au plus large consultation
nous voyons une collégialité efficace
mais bien entendu dans le cas que vous
évoquez en tout cas que vous suggérez
il ya nécessité de voir les choses de
près parce que le volume d'affaires
n'est pas le seul critère
merci mon cher collègue oui merci
même la garde des sceaux c'est vrai que
vous avez rappelé votre venue dans mon
département l'aveyron se fait un plaisir
de vous guider et j'espère que
d'ailleurs les parlementaires de ce
département arriveront à vous guider
vers vers la réparation de ce que ce
département a subi en matière de justice
puisque vous le savez je crois que ça a
été le département le plus touché par
les réformes successives qui ont fait
que aujourd'hui rodez l'aveyron dépend
d'un pôle de l'instruction à montpellier
et n'a plus de jurer de justice rendue
par un thé j'ai donc dans le sud aveyron
ce qui pose effectivement des problèmes
quand on connaît les contraintes de
temps de déplacement de ce département
les problèmes climatiques qu'il peut
qu'on peut rencontrer
et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je
n'insisterai juste là dessus attirer
votre attention sur le fait que même un
principe pour lequel on est tous
convaincus qu'il faut le préserver c'est
à dire la possibilité pour tout un
chacun de choisir un avocat et choisir
un avocat dans le secteur idc choisir un
avocat l'aide juridictionnelle faut pas
confondre la commission d'office et
l'aide juridictionnelle ou les avocats
peuvent accepter de défendre quelqu'un
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas s'il ya trop
de distance entre le lieu où le client
se trouve est le lieu où la justice est
rendue donc je crois que c'est sur la
base de ces grands principes que nous
devons de mettre avaié très bien merci
alors justement vous l'avez cité la
parole et au président jean jacques
hyest
merci monsieur le président madame la
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues je
crois qu'il faut saluer le rapport vous
l'avez déjà fait ma miss le rapport de
nos collègues virginie klès yves
detraigne sur l'axé la justice sur la
justice de proximité
ce rapport n'aura pas seulement eu le
mérite de faire appel de tous
les réflexions qui ont été menées dans
ce domaine il va plus loin et avance des
propositions sur ce que pourrait être la
réforme de la juridiction de première
instance
l'enjeu est aujourd'hui de retrouver un
équilibre entre lisibilité accessibilité
il faut reconnaître qu'il ya beaucoup
d'efforts à faire dans ce domaine entre
accès à la justice et proximité nous
savons par ailleurs que la capacité du
législateur a dessiné les périmètres de
chaque contentieux sera déterminante
afin de mener à bien une réforme durable
dans ce domaine la modernisation de la
carte judiciaire qu'il est de bon ton de
critiquer mais en fait que vous n'êtes
pas modifier un à ma garde des sceaux à
une exception j'ai dit à une exception
près moi je ne fais pas de citations
particulière a eu le mérite d'engager
concrètement un processus qui s'était
limitée auparavant une réflexion qui
durait depuis plus de vingt ans aux 25
ans puisque la dernière réforme c'était
59 je crois et je regrette madame la
garde des sceaux qu'on n'a pas été plus
loin notamment en ce qui concerne les
cours d'appel
fermons la parenthèse je vais fâché
quelques-uns aujourd'hui madame le garde
des sceaux cela fait 18 mois que vous
êtes arrivée à la chancellerie aux
travaux déjà accumulé songe ajouter
divers supports qui devrait moureu
nourrir votre réflexion bien sûr le
rapport que je viens de citer
mais aussi les réflexions la directrice
elle fer judiciaire sans oublier le
rapport guinchard il ya eu le rapport
cazorla que vous citez ou encore les
débats relatifs au report de la
suppression des juridictions de
proximité pour autant attendez vous la
grand-messe de janvier vous restait
encore flou sur les orientations que
vous allez donner à la réforme prochaine
de la première instance
est-ce qu'on va créer un tribunal de
premier instance englobera t-il
l'ensemble des juridictions de proximité
tribunaux d'instance tribunaux de
commerce conseil de prud'hommes malgré
la réticence des juges qui sont élus
dans certaines de ces juridictions
dans le cas où cette juridiction
disposerait d'antenne déconcentrer ça
peut aussi une hypothèse comment allez
vous dépassez les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité relatifs à l'égal
accès de tous à la justice et aux
principes sacrés d'inamovibilité des
magistrats du siège
c'est peut-être beaucoup des questions
en une seule madame la garde des sceaux
mais je pense merci beaucoup c'est bien
madame la ministre monsieur le président
je vois permettez moi de prendre
quelques secondes pour saluer le
sénateur vallini et le rassurer sur nous
avons été informés des incidents qui
vient de survenir et la direction des
services judiciaires seront
immédiatement sur place
monsieur le président y est
il ya eu d'effondrement de
l'effondrement d'une passerelle entre
les bâtiments judiciaires et une
personne blessée
monsieur monsieur le président y est
alors sur eux la justice de proximité
c'est une réalité vous dit quand on
critique la carte judiciaire je n'ai pas
encore fait mais je vais je vais je vais
dire j'ai renforcé ce qu'a dit le
sénateur mazin la réforme judiciaire la
réforme de la carte judiciaire n'est
contesté par personne
elle était nécessaire la méthode a été
mise en cause y compris d'ailleurs par
les magistrats y compris par les cours
d'appel qui avait travaillé qui ont fait
les propositions des suggestions il est
incontestable que dans certains
territoires cet art judiciaire cette
réforme de la carte judiciaire a créé de
vraies désert judiciaire et les déserts
judiciaire aucun d'entre nous ici ne
peut se sont accommodés puisque c'est un
éloignement de la justice pour le
justiciable
alors vous avez évoqué il ya eu des
bruits des vocations
un peu sonore en tout cas audible à ma
place sur les décisions de voilà deux
ouvertures de tribunaux pas vous mais
vous avez toujours cette élégance là
monsieur le président je vous la
reconnaît mais puisque j'ai la parole je
réponds je rappelle que les conditions
dans lesquelles j'ai fait procéder à
l'arrêt a vu une réévaluation de la
situation de certains territoires
ces conditions sont absolument objectif
je me suis contenté de faire réévaluer
les villes qui avaient fait l'objet
d'observations de la part du rapporteur
public devant le conseil d'état
pas une de plus pas une de moins alors
c'est aux critères objectifs et puisque
j'ai entendu évoquer tulle tu le fais
partie des trois tribunaux de grande
instance effectivement que nous allons
rétablir avec saint-gaudens et saumur
tué quand même la seule préfecture qui
ait perdu son tribunal de grande
instance
alors je crois qu'il ya plus de
questions sur les réseaux pollet calcul
a perdu 100 tribunal
que les raisons pour lesquelles tu y vas
retrouver son tribunal de grande
instance
les éléments sont parfaitement objectif
pour justifier la réouverture du
tribunal de grande instance de tulle
donc nous combattants c'est désert
judiciaire et il ya plusieurs réponses
effectivement l'excellent rapport de
madame play et de monsieur détraigne
offre un certain nombre de propositions
les chantiers que j'ai ouvert la
réflexion ce n'est pas une grand-messe
monsieur le président y est la justice
mérite que nous mettions les
intelligences ensemble elles méritent
que nous mettions les énergies ensemble
elles méritent que nous travaillons
ensemble à améliorer les conditions dans
lesquelles justiciable peut avoir
recours à la justice est ce que nous
faisons vous êtes largement invités à
cet événement de janvier qui sera une
étape parce que à partir de ce travail
effectué en public de mise en commun de
ces réflexions sur la base et
préconisent les préconisations de cette
date de ces quatre rapports pardon je
vais ouvrir un cycle de concertation je
me déplace des gens juridiction les
assemblées générales vont traiter de ces
sujets dont nous avons nous allons
avancer mais la méthode est vraiment
l'écriture commune
merci su président soyez bref si vous le
pouvez oui madame le garde des sceaux
j'ai bien entendu mais moi je sais je me
méfie beaucoup des conférences de
consensus et c'est parce que non
la loi c'est ici quand j'entendais ce
matin professeur dans un colloque dire
que dire que le dép le législateur n'a
qu'à faire les lois point à la ligne
et tout le reste il ne s'en préoccupe
pas on a aussi la charge d'évaluer avant
ce que c'est quand même notre métier
pour faire une bonne loi il faut savoir
de quoi on parle
et s'il ya des rapports d'information
aussi précieux et je crois monsieur le
président que le sénat s'est toujours
illustré dans ce domaine c'est aussi
parce que nous avons nous une expertise
et pas seulement celle des spécialistes
et quand j'entends je vous le dis
franchement quand j'entends que ça
devrait et magistrats qui nous dise
comment il faut faire
je pense que autant je respecte le
magistrat dans son activité
juridictionnelle autant le corporatisme
est un bel exemple de cette noble
corporation
il y en a pas les seuls mais si on
demande aux professionnels de se
réformer
vous savez très bien que ça ne se fait
jamais et donc c'est pour ça je sais
très bien ce que vous allez faire au
moins de l'envié j'essaierai d'y même
d'y participer vous voyez mais il n'en
demeure pas mois que ça n'est pas le
lieu où les décisions pourraient être
prises
c'est un éclairage ça doit s'arrêter là
de mon point de vue très bien merci
merci monsieur le président la parole à
notre collègue yves détraigne pour le
groupe
udi uc merci monsieur le président
madame madame la garde des sceaux à mon
tour de parler du rapport qui était chat
est évoquée par plusieurs de mes
collègues et par vous même que nous
avons présentés virginie klès et
moi-même en octobre dernier à la
commission des lois dans l'objectif de
faciliter l'accès à la justice pour nos
concitoyens malgré la suppression des
nombreuses implantations judiciaire qui
a résulté de la récente réforme de la
carte judiciaire et bien dans ce rapport
nous avons fait le choix de proposer
l'amélioration de l'accès à la justice
pour nos concitoyens en adoptant je dois
le dire une démarche que l'on veut
pragmatique
celle ci consiste principalement à
proposer la fusion des juridictions de
première instance
en premier lieu les tribunaux d'instance
et tribunaux de grande instance bien sûr
dans un tribunal de première instance
unique dont les lieux de justice
existant actuellement constituerez
autant de portes d'entrée
quel que soit le tribunal compétent du
ressort pour s'occuper de son affaire le
justiciable n'aurait à s'adresser qu'à
un seul greffe le plus proche de son
domicile pour s'informer engagé sa
procédure ou suivent son avancement
cette formule de guichet universel du
greffe c'est ainsi que nous l'avons
appelé intéressante pour faciliter
l'accès du justiciable injustice sans
procéder à une nouvelle réforme de la
carte judiciaire nécessite toutefois que
quelques préalables soient remplies afin
de pouvoir la mettre en oeuvre dans les
meilleures conditions
outre notamment le rapprochement des
procédures entre les actuels juridiction
de premier degré et la mutualisation des
effectifs de greffe du tribunal
d'instance du conseil des prud'hommes et
du tribunal de grande instance dans le
périmètre du ressort de ce dernier
il est indispensable si l'on ne veut pas
connaître les mêmes difficultés que
celles que l'on a connues à une autre
époque dans le domaine pénal avec la
mise en oeuvre de l'application
informatique cassiopée que soit mené
prioritairement à son terme le
développement de la chaîne civile
informatique portalis qui permettra de
connaître en temps réel et quel que soit
le guichet du greffe auquel on
s'adressera dans le ressort du thé pays
l'état d'avancement d'une procédure
pouvez vous donc madame la ministre nous
dire où l'on en est du développement et
de la mise en oeuvre de l'application
portalis jeu merci merci madame l'odeur
de son président monsieur le sénateur
détraigne a là je réponds d'une phrase à
monsieur le président en liesse avec
votre autorisation
la consultation les groupes de travail
ne rassemble pas seulement des
magistrats il s'y trouve des avocats des
policiers des gendarmes des préfets
voilà des universitaires etc donc mais
évidemment la main sur la loi là mais
définitif sur la loi c'est vous qui
l'aurait bien entendu et je sais la
capacité de nos chambres nous
parlementaires éventuellement à écrire
des textes de lois c'est arrivé par le
passé mais nous vous présenterons un
texte assez solides pour que vous n'ayez
pas le réécrire complètement monsieur le
sénateur détraigne vous faites des
propositions à extrêmement élaboré que
j'ai que le cabinet l'administration et
moi même avons étudié attentivement et
incontestablement je l' ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises
votre rapport est versée au dossier de
la réforme judiciaire puisque nous le
diffusons très largement et nous allons
continuer à y travailler
concernant portalis alors pour
consciemment portalis cet applicatif
civile qui il faut savoir que ces
dernières années ces dernières années il
ya eu des efforts sur les applicatifs
informatiques il ya il y en a eu
notamment en matière de justice pénale
avec l'applicatif cassiopée que vous
savez que nous interconnectant nous
avons déjà interconnectés avec la
gendarmerie et que nous continuons à
interconnecter que la police nous allons
achever avec la police dans le courant
de l'année
2014 en sachant que nous venons de
signer une convention avec le préfet de
police qui nous permettra de faire une
expérimentation dans le 11e
arrondissement de paris donc nous
avançons là nous allons continuer à
étendre cassiopée notamment cour d'appel
et puis sur les la justice spécialisée
concernant l'instruction ou la justice
des enfants
les efforts qui ont été faits ces
dernières années ont donc concernés
cassiopée 60 milliards d'euros.le la
plateforme d'interceptions judiciaires
pour 36 millions d'euros et portalis est
estimé actuellement à 41 millions
d'euros
nous avons une vraie difficulté en
matière de d'applicatifs civil d'abord
de connexion sur l'ensemble du
territoire
il y à quelques procédés qui sont en
application il ya un très compliqué qui
s'appelle citrix ification à peu près il
ya un autre qui est un procédé web
il y à il ya un autre dispositif oui le
visio visio justice contacter lise au
contact justice mais on voit bien que ce
n'est pas satisfaisant il nous faut un
applicatif sur l'ensemble du territoire
qu'ils puissent mailler tout le
territoire et avoir une portée nationale
nous pensons que dans quatre ans à peu
près nous devrions être en mesure de
commencer à appliquer portalis en
sachant que ce sera long que ça va
s'étaler dans le temps que c'est coûteux
mais ce sera une priorité pour le
prochain triennal merci en quelques
secondes s'il vous plaît mon cher
collègue yves détraigne elle avait la
garde des sceaux
merci de votre explication qui ne me
rassure pas complètement parce qu'il est
clair que si on veut réussir cette
réforme de la justice de proximité de la
justice de première instance
aujourd'hui ça passe forcément à un
moment ou à un autre par un outil
informatique qui soit tout à fait
efficace donc je crois qu'il va falloir
en même temps que le vent ait poussé
lancée et pousser la réflexion sur
l'organisation de la justice du 21e
siècle
il faut pas oublier de mettre les
crédits nécessaires je sais que c'est
compliqué aujourd'hui mais de mettre les
crédits nécessaires pour que les moyens
techniques indispensables
suivent au même rythme eh bien merci la
parole à philippe kaltenbach pour le
groupe socialiste
chers collègues si vous permettez
si vous permettez je passe la parole à
philippe cals d'un bac merci monsieur le
président madame la garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues ma question porte
sur les droits des victimes
depuis trente ans les gouvernements
successifs de gauche comme de droite
d'ailleurs ont permis à la france
d'acquérir un dispositif solide en
matière de droits des victimes
je souhaitais d'ailleurs sur ce point
rendre hommage à l'un de nos anciens
éminents collègues
grand artisan de ce dispositif en tant
que garde des sceaux je pense bien sûr à
robert badinter
on peut dire aujourd'hui que la france
est un bon élève de la classe europe
néanmoins la pratique se révèle être
plus mitigé que la théorie est à l'heure
actuelle
force est de constater que des
faiblesses entravent encore l'accès à la
justice et le droit des victimes
ces faiblesses sont tout d'abord liée à
la complexité des dispositifs existants
la victime peut en effet connaître des
difficultés dans ses démarches de
concision partie civile il convient
également de souligner un manque
d'information la remise d'un simple
formulaire souvent rédigées dans les
termes peu accessible ne saurait être
une réponse parfaitement adaptée aux
attentes des victimes qui sont déjà
fragilisés l'accompagnement la victime
doit également être renforcée les
bureaux des deux victimes ont d'une part
besoin de moyens financiers
supplémentaires mais également de moyens
humains et je pense notamment aux
greffiers qui sont indispensables si on
veut des bureaux des deux victimes qui
fonctionne correctement
par ailleurs je regrette ces dernières
années les associations d'aidé aux
victimes ont dû faire face à des baisses
de leurs subventions pour conforter leur
rôle essentiel dans l'accompagnement des
victimes
un soutien plus important doit leur être
alloué et leurs subventions doivent être
pérennisés
j'ai même envie de dire century zh et au
delà de l'accès à la justice je pense
également qu'il faut en finir avec une
indemnisation inégalitaire des victimes
l'absence de référentiel indicatif au
niveau national a pour conséquence une
forte variation dans l'indemnisation des
victimes
pour ne citer que quelques exemples une
incapacité
enfin je veux en rien la question à
monsieur le président avec mon collègue
christophe béchu nous avons
rendu un rapport sur les dispositifs
d'indemnisation des victimes nous avons
voulu remettre mais je souhaiterais
madame la ministre profiter de
l'occasion qui m'est donnée pour vous
interroger sur les mesures que vous
comptez prendre de façon à ce que la
condition des victimes soient mieux
prises en compte
à chaque stade du procès pénal je vous
remercie madame la ministre c'est le
président monsieur le sénateur kaltene
bac je devais vous recevoir d'ailleurs
pour la remise de ce rapport d'une
contraintes d'agenda mâcon m'a obligée à
reporter mais le rendez vous je sais le
prochain rendez-vous est déjà fixé pour
ce rapport que vous avez rédigé et que
votre collègue monsieur béchu j'ai
évidemment commencer à regarder sans
contenu donc j'ai vu la trentaine de
propositions que vous faites vous savez
à quel point ce gouvernement efforts
engagés aux côtés des victimes même si
nous avons décidé des libérables
délibérément et résolument de ne pas
instrumentaliser des victimes de ne pas
faire de tapage autour des actions que
nous conduisons mais dès le premier
budget nous avons augmenté l'aide aux
victimes de 25 8% alors que le budget
des victimes ne sais c'est de baisser
depuis 2010
nous l'avons augmenté de 25,8 pour cent
nous l'avons augmenté encore pour
l'année 2014 de près de 8% et nous avons
ouvert les bureaux des deux victimes
dans tous nos tribunaux de grande
instance
en une année nous en avons ouvert une
centaine comme je m'y étais engagé
devant vous alors qu'il n'existait
qu'une cinquantaine ouvert sur les trois
années précédentes nous mobilisons
évidemment les associations à qui nous
exprimant d'ailleurs notre gratitude
pour leur travail vous savez que dès
juin 2013 j'ai demandé à l'inspection
générale des services judiciaires de
procéder à une évaluation de ses bureaux
d'aidé aux victimes de façon à ce que
nous puissions ajouté ajuster les
réponses que nous devons apporter à
leurs besoins nous avons déjà commencé à
mettre en place un certain nombre de 10
de préconisations tels que par exemple
au renforcement de la dotation pour le
premier équipement tel que aussi
l'inclusion de ces bureaux des deux
victimes
dans l'agenda de la juridiction tels que
le développement de permanence le soir
ou le week-end donc nous essayons
d'apporter un service actif aux victimes
vous savez que nous allons beaucoup plus
loin puisque j'ai décidé de
d'expérimenter avant même la
transposition de la directive victimes
d'octobre 2012 que nous pouvons proposer
jusqu'à novembre 2015
avant même la transposition j'ai décidé
de lancer une expérimentation sur le
suivi individualisé des victimes dans
les préconisations que vous faites je
sais que vous proposez un barème unique
de façon à harmoniser le la réponse
apportée aux victimes
je souhaite que l'individualisation soit
maintenue mais effectivement j'ai
conscience qu'il est nécessaire de
disposer de référentiels sur l'ensemble
du territoire
par conséquent nous allons rassembler
ces éléments pour que les juridictions
puisse en disposer
merci s'il vous plaît en quelques
secondes moins chers collègues je tiens
à remercier madame la garde des sceaux
pour l'ensemble de ses réponses
je crois qu'il est important de
conjuguer responsabilisation de l'auteur
et protection de la victime
celle ci a besoin en effet de la même
attention que celle qui est accordé à
l'auteur et ce dans un souci de justice
et d'équité
je sais que c'est l'une de vos
principales préoccupations et nous
faisons pleinement confiance pour mener
à bien les réformes nécessaires merci
merci merci bien la parole albéric de
montgolfier pour le groupe ump
merci et surprise vous connaissez même
pas la question n'a pas dit ce n'est pas
merci madame lagarde est sommée sur
collègue madame le garde des sceaux
parfois votre politique manque de
visibilité je pense en particulier au
débat sur la politique pénale et on le
dit souvent mais là je voudrais vous à
tanger sur une question que là aussi on
a besoin de clarifications qui est celle
de l'aide juridictionnelle l'aide
juridictionnelle puisque on a bien
compris que vous ne souhaitiez pas
mettre le gouvernement dans l'embarras
et que vous avez donc décidé de reporter
la réforme de l'aide juridictionnelle
au delà de 2014 peut-être en 2015 et sur
le fond je le dis clairement nous ne
pouvons qu'approuver ce report ce recul
du gouvernement sur un sujet qui mettait
en difficulté à la fois la profession
d'avocat parce que la profession
d'avocat fait preuve parfois d'un
véritable sens civique en travaillant
pour des sommes modestes au bénéfice des
plus démunis mais ça mettait également
en difficulté cette réforme les
justiciables qui vais risquer de voir
l'offre des services se réduire avec une
diminution des moyens du fait des
difficultés des cabinets qui aurait
souffert d'une baisse de leurs moyens
mis à disposition pour à bien cette
mission
et pour autant malgré cette reculade la
question du financement demeure toujours
d'actualité puisque le projet de loi de
finances pour 2014 prévoit une baisse
des crédits de 32 millions d'euros
consacrés à l'aide juridictionnelle
c'est donc un problème budgétaire qui
met hammam qui met à mal par dont le
principe même de l'aide juridictionnelle
et vous êtes resté même regardé soit
assez floue à ce sujet je en veux pour
preuve aux propos tenus deux lors de
l'assemblée extraordinaire du conseil
national des barreaux en disant je vous
cite explorons jusqu'au bout chaque
piste à charge pour vous de la récuser
et je crois que pour notre part nous ne
pouvons accepter que la ministre en
charge en responsabilité sur ce sujet d'
sur ce sujet demande aux acteurs du
secteur en l'occurrence les avocats
d'assumer ce non choix
alors ma question est très simple prêtre
dans le temps madame ministre faut-il
encore compter sur de nouvelles taxes ou
de nouveau à pau pour financer la
refonte de l'aide juridictionnelle est
en tous les cas pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur vos attentions sur les
pistes que vous envisagez pour réformer
cette aide juridictionnelle
au delà de l'année 2014 qui est celle de
la passe budgétaire merci madame la
ministre
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur trois procès en un en deux
minutes c'est un exploit
alors je vais vous répondre sur le flou
du débat du débat pénal pardon oui cela
fout du oui oui nous aurons l'occasion
de venir mais bon c'est c'est une
pratique à laquelle je me suis fortement
habitué depuis 18 mois sur l'aide
juridictionnelle alors ils vous voient
bien de saluer l'engagement des avocats
alors que vous n'avez pas revalorisé
l'unité de valeur depuis 2007 c'est à
dire pendant tout un quinquennat vous
n'avez pas fait bouger d'un centime
d'euro l'unité de valeur servi aux
avocats donc c'est bien c'est bien de
leur rendre hommage parce
qu'effectivement ceux qui pratiquent
l'aide juridictionnelle pratique là un
véritable engagement civique nous
qu'avons nous fait je vous rappelle
qu'un rapport du sénat d'ailleurs parmi
les six rapports qui existent depuis une
dizaine d'années il ya un rapport du
sénat qui date de 2007
le rapport lu ar et qui s'intitulait
lui-même réformer un système à bout de
souffle
en 2007 pendant tout un quinquennat vous
n'avez pas trouvé un mois pour réformer
machin alors vous êtes étonnés que je
mal à la profession et que je dise nous
avons mis des pistes sur la table je
vous propose de d'explorer ses plus
piste avant l'erreur de les récuser
pardon oui effectivement il ya une
grande différence de méthode entre ce
que vous faisiez est ce que nous faisons
nous ne réformons pas à l'encontre des
professions nous réformons avec des
professions nous respectons les
professions et nous travaillons avec
elle
donc effectivement nous mettons des
pistes sur la table et nous discutons
nous concertons nous nous consultons les
professions de façon à aboutir une bonne
réforme
il ya plus de dix ans qu'aucun
gouvernement n'a eu le courage de
réformer l'aide juridictionnelle et l'a
donc fragilisé la fragiliser mais nous
nous allons aboutir à une consolidation
une pérennisation du financement de
l'aide juridictionnelle
parce que l'aide juridictionnelle est
tout simplement une politique de
solidarité vis-à-vis des justiciables
les plus vulnérables il n'y en droit
easy endroit en deça même du seuil de
pauvreté
par conséquent il faut consolider cette
politique de solidarité
donc nous le faisons nous continuons à
travailler vous savez que j'ai chargé
monsieur carrez pierrât d'une mission
qui permet effectivement de continuer la
discussion avec les professions de façon
à aboutir avant le prochain budget à une
un financement de l'aide
juridictionnelle
vous n'avez ni un quart de mots un quart
de mots sur la suppression des 35 euros
que vous aviez instauré et qui constitue
une véritable entrave à l'accès au juge
et qui a pénalisé des justiciables plus
vulnérables nous avons choisi d'aborder
le budget de la justice de 60 millions
d'euros afin de subir ce têt ce timbre
de 35 ans merci mon cher collègue
quelques secondes si vous voulez bien
vraiment je remercierai le ministre de
manifester son attachement à la joe
dickson messapresse budgétaire puisque à
16 heures j'ai rejoint la cmp à
l'assemblée nationale et on va constater
quoi on va là sans doute échoué dans la
cmp
mais on va constater la baisse de 32
millions d'euros consacrés à l'aide
juridictionnelle
donc la réalité est là et quant aux
pistes bien le question restait ouverte
et on sera très vigilant pour redébattre
merci beaucoup merci
la parole est à michel monnier pour le
groupe socialiste sur le président du
sénat madame la ministre
en prolongement de la journée
internationale
25 novembre je souhaite madame la
ministre vous redire ma préoccupation
sur la question des violences envers les
filles et les femmes de notre pays je
sais l'engagement de la ministre aux
droits des femmes et je sais aussi votre
mobilisation sur ce sujet quelques
chiffres à rappeler hélas les victimes
de violences sexuelles sont à 80% des
femmes et 50% des violences sexuelles
sont commises sur des filles de moins de
15 ans le nombre de viols de mineurs et
deux majeurs est estimé à 190 milles en
france les viols sont majoritairement le
fait d'hommes ou de garçons proches de
la victime et de ce fait très peu
dénoncé auprès de la justice car les
victimes sont prisonnières de l'emprise
et de la peur la loi du silence protège
les auteurs puisque le nombre de
plaintes est faible et les condamnations
rarissime moins de 2% des viols font
l'objet d'une condamnation
une femme sur dix vivant en couple est
victime de violences conjugales en 2012
166 femmes et 31 hommes ont été tués par
leur compagne ou compagnon ou ex
compagnes compagnons ainsi que 25
enfants
cette situation madame la ministre est
un véritable fléau qui ternit notre
société il y a aucune fatalité à ces
comportements
ils n'y ont il n'ya aucune fatalité à
ces comportements
il n'y a qu'à l'habitude et éducation
nous le savons bien
la justice par des vertus pédagogiques
de la sanction a un rôle important à
jouer en la matière à condition que
celle ci cessent d'apparaître aux yeux
des victimes et aux associations qui les
accompagnent comme une justice parfois
aléatoire optionnel voir inégalitaire je
voudrais savoir madame la ministre
quelles mesures avez-vous déjà prévues
afin de garantir l'application des
textes existant en la matière et
permettre ainsi que les délais
d'application soient mieux adaptés aux
besoins des victimes
par ailleurs quelles mesures
comptez-vous prendre concernant
l'application effective de la convention
d'istanbul texte de référence en matière
de prise en charge des victimes de
violences et de lutte contre
violence à l'égard des femmes pro bio
merci en deux minutes
vite madame la sénatrice meunier je
connais votre engagement et celui de
plusieurs des sénatrices et sénateurs
sur cette question c'est un vrai drame
parce qu'en plus des violences
pratiquées sur les femmes dans le milieu
conjugal il y a les enfants qui sont
témoins de ces violences qui sont
parfois même aussi victimes de ces
violences donc nous avons une politique
résolument tourné vers l'accompagnement
et la protection des victimes vous savez
que j'ai décidé cette année de réunir
deux fois par année
le conseil national d'aidé aux victimes
qui travaille sur les victimes les
violences faites aux femmes
c'est un conseil qui n'avaient pas été
réunies depuis l'année 2010 donc nous
l'avons réuni deux fois nous le
modernise en modifiant sa composition et
nous le faisons travailler régulièrement
par ailleurs vous savez que la justice
et la chancellerie est partie prenante
du quatrième plan interministériel de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
nous y avons travaillé dans le texte de
l'égalité hommes femmes notamment pour
améliorer les conditions de prononcer de
l' ordonnance de protection augmenter la
durée et permettre le renouvellement
nous généralisons le téléphone de grands
dangers je suis en train de lancer le
marché national donc ce sont l'ensemble
du territoire
les femmes pourront être protégés avec
des structures départementales qui
décline la politique nationale nous
sommes en train de travailler mieux sur
l'éviction du conjoint violent mais
également sur des stages de
sensibilisation de façon à faire en
sorte qu' il n'y ait pas de réitération
pas de récidive de la part de ces
conjoints violents
par ailleurs avec la ministre des droits
des femmes et le ministre de l'intérieur
nous avons lancé une le traitement des
mains courantes vous savez que j'ai
lancé une formation pour les magistrats
les policiers les gendarmes et les
services sociaux
les personnels des services sociaux pour
mieux recueillir les plains les plaintes
pour mieux accompagner et mieux entendre
je diffuserai bientôt une circulaire de
façon à appeler les parcs et à mieux
présent prendre en compte ce type de
violences en particulier concernant la
convention d'istanbul vous savez que
nous l'avons transposer récemment dans
le droit français dans
nous avons introduit dans notre code
pénal les dispositions de protection des
femmes victimes de violence de violences
conjugales et de viande sur la
correctionnalisation des viols qui est
scandaleuse et trop fréquente même si
elle se fait avec l'approbation de la
victime
j'ai lancé une évaluation qui nous
permettent de voir exactement les
conditions dans lesquelles cette
correctionnalisation d'un crime se
produit dans notre pays bien merci merci
madame la ministre vraiment en quelques
secondes leurs collègues c'était pour
remercier mal la ministre d'ouvrir tous
ces chantiers et de redire que sur le
terrain à l'échelle du département
l'évaluation et la mise en application
les modalités d'application sont aussi
donc à observer à évaluer pour faire en
sorte qu'une marche aussi bien sur nos
deux pieds très bien la parole à
christian cambon pour le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre dans ses nombreuses promesses
électorale le candidat françois hollande
s'était notamment également engagé à
faciliter l'accès pour tous à la justice
de proximité
or cette justice de proximité cela a été
dit tout au long de cette séance marche
mal elle est compliquée lente et
coûteuse et elle ne contribue pas
toujours à la bonne image de ce service
public
c'est cette justice néanmoins que les
français vivent au quotidien car par
chance ils ne sont pas tous délinquants
ou criminels
deux jugements sur trois concernent en
effet les actes et gérer et les
événements simple quelquefois souvent
dramatiques qui frappent les français
dans leur vie de tous les jours et pour
lesquels ils sollicitent l'aide de la
justice divorce licenciement
surendettement conflits familiaux
conflits de voisinage qui engorgent les
tribunaux or le constat nous les élus
nous l'entendons de la bouche de nos
concitoyens les procédures sont trop
complexes
le coût de la justice est trop élevé les
délais pour obtenir une décision de
justice sont trop longs l'image négative
de la justice résulte certes parfois de
l'incompréhension de certaines peines
prononcées dans un temps où l'opinion
réclame plus de sévérité
mais elle tient tout autant à la
difficulté pour le justiciable d'obtenir
justice dans ces conflits du quotidien
or il semble que depuis votre arrivée à
la chancellerie vous ayez consacré
beaucoup d'énergie à faire adopter des
réformes sociétales dont la nécessité
immédiate
ne sautez pas toujours aux yeux
vous vous lancez aujourd'hui dans une
réforme de la justice pénale qui risque
encore peut-être d'aggraver le divorce
entre l'opinion publique et
l'institution judiciaire
dès lors ne serait-il pas légitime avant
de vouloir diminuer le nombre de détenus
en prison d'apporter des réponses
concrètes à cette justice de proximité à
cette justice de tous les jours et donc
pas d'âme la ministe pouvez vous nous
donner en conclusion de cette séance
votre éclairage sur les réflexions sur
tous les projets mais aussi les moyens
financiers que vous souhaitez mettre en
oeuvre et en chantier pour qu'enfin la
justice de notre pays devienne
accessible compréhensible et plus
efficace pour le quotidien
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur je trouve
de grandes vertus à votre question la
première c'est que vous avez rappelé
l'important de la justice civile
et je rappelle à longueur de temps que
la justice civile concerne 70 % de
l'activité de l'institution judiciaire
c'est la justice du quotidien c'est la
justice qui répond au problème
d'endettement d'expulsion de logements
de la justice familiale
donc il ya toute une série de problèmes
discret mais qui sont essentiels pour
les justiciables
la deuxième grande vertu que je trouve à
votre question c'est que finalement elle
constitue un bilan de l'action de
l'ancien quai que sous l'ancien
quinquennat de l'ancien gouvernement
parce que vous avez montré à quel point
effectivement avec des outils que l'on
connaît parfaitement la rgpp c'est à
dire la révision générale des politiques
publiques c'est-à-dire la carte
judiciaire qui a créé des déserts
judiciaire qui a supprimé 80 postes de
magistrats et avec l'annoncé par la rgpp
du non remplacement d'un départ sur deux
à la retraite
effectivement depuis l'année dernière
monsieur le sénateur ce gouvernement a
rompu il a rompu puisque le budget de la
justice est en augmentation il a été de
4,3 pour cent l'année dernière il est de
1,7 pour cent cette année parce que nous
avons mis un terme à la rgpp et que nous
avons nous nous créons des emplois
nous créons plus de 500 emplois 590 pour
cette année 2014
nous créons des emplois nous travaillons
pour
améliorez justement le bilan l'héritage
que vous avez laissé l'héritage que vous
avez laissé c'est à dire non seulement
les déchets judiciaire non seulement la
multiplication des contraintes des
fonctions des obligations qui ont abouti
à l'engorgement de nos juridictions avec
pour principale conséquence le
rallongement des délais donc la
pénalisation des justiciables
nous sommes en train de réparer tout
cela j'espère que vous aurez à vous en
réjouir très bientôt
il suffit simplement d'accepter les
réalités les données les informations
plutôt que de nous faire des procès vous
discutez toujours de choses que vous
croyez être je vous propose simplement
de débattre ensemble et je crois que
c'est un peu la culture de cette maison
de débattre ensemble des réalités et le
travail qui est produit dans ce
gouvernement depuis un an et demi est au
travail qui permettent d'améliorer
justement la justice est de faire en
sorte que les paramètres que l'on peut
mesurer notamment les délais s'améliore
merci mon cher collègue christian cambon
je présente mes amis je vous ai
interrogé et respectueusement vous
donnant l'occasion au final de cette
réunion d'exposer vos projets et comme
c'est une tradition dans ce gouvernement
vous passez votre temps à nous parler de
l'héritage alors si les français vous
ont élu c'est pas pour commenter le
passé c'est pour agir pour l'avenir et
donc j'ai perçu quelques éléments de
réponse pour l'avenir j'espère que vous
serez à la hauteur des engagements que
vous avez pris je vous signale au dépôt
au passage que comme la réponse que vous
aviez fait sur les personnels
pénitentiaires
vous utilisez des éléments qui ne sont
pas exacts puisqu'ils n'y a pas eu de
rgpp en matière de justice
mais enfin c'est une précision que les
téléspectateurs apprécieront
j'espère en tous les cas que nous aurons
l'occasion de débattre y compris sur les
grandes réformes pénales sur lequel il
ya encore beaucoup à dire merci madame
très bien merci merci madame la ministre
merci mes chers collègues je vais lever
la séance
je vais appeler l'ordre du jour
voilà vous avez pu suivre en direct de
l'hémicycle la séance de questions
cribles des questions consacré à l'accès
à la justice et la justice de proximité
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
sur public sénat c'est le 24 heures
sénat à 19 heures présenté par delphine
girard